- And I see that turkey winking at me!
Hi turkey face!
(classical music)
Thanksgiving in our
family, is a main event.
- I came from a large family.
Everybody got together on Thanksgiving.
- Everyone who doesn't have a place to go.
- We say come.
- Oh, you have to have a turkey, yeah.
- It's a tradition.
- Oh my goodness, no
turkey, no Thanksgiving.
- The turkey is the main (record scratch)
- But not for me.
If it's not kosher, I don't eat it.
I'm afraid of the man upstairs.
(turkey gobbles)
- Wait a second, oh my God. (laughter)
- Okay.
- Uh-huh.
- Do you have the turkey here?
- [Interviewer] I have the turkey here.
- Can't wait.
(turkey gobbles)
(playful music)
- [Grandma] Oh look!
- That's Thanksgiving?
- Huh, what's this orange stuff?
- Isn't that peaches,
on top of this turkey?
- Okay, I'm--
- Well, the turkey looks nice.
- Now watch me cut it, and watch me
put it in my mouth.
- Let me see if
she knows how to do that properly.
- Vamos.
- Actually, it's an
interesting combination.
- How is it?
Let me look at your mouth.
- It's okay.
- The turkey is not.
- A lot of bourbon in it?
No wonder it tastes better
than regular peaches.
- We will taste it again.
- It tastes like regular turkey.
- This is not as soft
as an oven baked turkey.
- How do you fry a big turkey?
You must have to have a big pot.
- This is delicious, I
might try the new turkey.
- It's (bleep) passable.
- It's good.
- I like to watch you eat.
- My sister is going to
insist that I eat it, because
she enjoys watching me
put the pounds on.
- I wouldn't eat it.
I want to see you eat it.
- But that's okay.
It's okay.
(turkey gobbles)
- [Grandma] Wait, wait, wait,
let me look at it first.
(gags) - What the (bleep) is this?
- Eww.
- A circular turkey.
- What is that?
- What the (bleep), I
can't eat this (bleep)!
- Oh, stuffing.
- It's, eye ye ye.
- Is that gristle?
- What, what?
- Stuffing!
(gags)
- Okay.
- I'm warning you, I get sick.
- Let me taste it, I
want to see what that is.
- Watch my sister watch me
eat, everyone.
- Look at, my eyes are open.
- Here we go.
- Here it goes, gobble gobble.
- Mmm.
- Not bad!
- Oh, my God!
- You see, when you see things
that you don't think you know.
- Turkey, duck, and chicken?
- Oh, my God.
- Turkduckin.
- Who?
- I'd never heard of that.
I don't think real people do this.
- But what is this?
I'm obsessed with this piece of fat.
- When I first saw it,
I didn't want to go near it.
- It wasn't too appetizing.
- Tasted it twice.
- More than passable, I can tell.
- A little (bleep) delicious.
- My review of turduckin is
a seven, cause of the fat.
- I think I want my sister to take
another sniff.
- I can't eat it.
Oh, a sniff I can do.
- Let her sniff at it, while I eat it.
Sniff it, sniff it little doggie.
- Oh, it does smell good.
(turkey gobbles)
- [Grandma] Here is goes.
- Surprise.
- Now this I don't know.
- That's turkey?
- And I think it looks,
- People like me.
- kinda delicious.
- What's on the outside,
cause that's really tough.
- Mmm, I don't know, what is this.
- Tastes almost like rubber?
- Rubber?!
- Oh I don't like that.
- No mas.
- I think I will give this
one to my sister. (laughter)
- You'll have to tell me what that is.
- It's supposed to be a vega,
how did you pronounce it?
- Vegan?
- Vegan dish food.
(coughing)
- Okay.
- To me, on Thanksgiving, I
would never look at this dish.
- That's very weird tasting,
I would not make that.
- I think this is a dish,
if you were on a desert,
and you were looking for something to eat.
- My review of tofur,
pho, toturkey, is one.
- You could use some of
my language if you'd like.
- It's freakin' bad.
- Oh my goodness, we almost got her
- to come over to my side!
(turkey gobbles)
- [Grandma] Would I ever
serve any of these turkeys?
- What is the one that I liked?
- Turducken.
- Truducken?
I would go for the turderken.
Turderken, turchicken.
It was turkey, chicken, and duck.
I would serve it, and know
that my family.
- Don't count me in.
- Wait one second, my normal
family members, would like it.
- I go back to the traditional one.
- I think there's
something about tradition
that's very important, but
truthfully, occasionally,
it'd be a good idea to
try something different.
- Just not with that tofu stuff.
- Let's try a different type of turkey,
and see what that feels like,
so that we just don't go
through life trying one thing.
We should all experience
as much as we can.
- A chocolate turkey
would be the best for me.
- That's a good idea.
- I love chocolate,
and that's my best.
Put the little chocolate
turkey in front of me,
and I'd eat it.
- A chocolate little turkey.
That's a good, gobble, gobble.
- Gobble, gobble.
- Let me ask you something,
that's the way you're gonna show
the turkey in the movie?
- [Interviewer] Oh, no, no.
- [Grandma] Wait, their
putting it on the turkey?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you're supposed to
put 'em out with it.
(laughing)